Los perdidos has been quarantined for  the safety of those both within and  without survivors should use extreme  caution when dealing with zombies after  dark hello anybody in here get away from  my clothes oh [ __ ]  [ __ ] take it Lana but it gets  interesting  pleasurable when I make a hike we gotta  get out of the city escape or die my  phone in my phone any song  you see if I can put something together  [Music]  [Music]  kill everything inside I'll bring it on  my chest pop open easily disagree we  really need it buddy  I'm still looking for him we professed  to trap I didn't the hell out of the  city taking my friends with where's that  damn karaoke bar  [Music]  [Music]